[Music]
hey guys I'm chastity with your guide to
the top gaming trilogy's delivered by
Pizza Hut an honor of pizza hut's triple
treat box we're highlighting triple
treats of video games why give your
friends and loved ones just one video
game when you can give them three times
the fun first up is uncharted the nathan
drake collection the Uncharted series
combines third-person action cover-based
shooting and cinematic storytelling the
nathan drake collection includes the
first three games of the series drake's
Fortune among thieves and drake's
Deception follow nathan drake across
deserts between mountains and
underground through ancient tombs in
these three epic games available only
for ps4 for 1999 next is the Batman
Arkham series for the Batman fan in your
life this action series is a ton of fun
from cool gadgets too slick combat two
awesome stealth gameplay being Batman
has never been so satisfying two of the
games took the world record for most
critically acclaimed superhero game ever
Batman Arkham Asylum and batman arkham
city come in a neat pack called Batman
returned to Arkham for ps4 or Xbox one
for 4999 round out your batman trilogy
with Arkham Knight the stunning
conclusion to the series for 1999 next
we have bioshock the collection if you
haven't played a bioshock game yet this
is the best way to experience them the
Bioshock series features some of the
best story driven first-person shooters
you'll ever play using impressive
storytelling you'll go on epic journeys
through the cities of rapture and
Columbia this remastered collection
includes bioshock bioshock two and
bioshock infinite it's available for PC
ps4 and Xbox one for 59 99 for those
mischief-makers on your listeners Grand
Theft Auto the trilogy this compilation
calls back to the third era of the
open-world Grand Theft Auto series it
includes GTA 3 vice city and san andreas
for the nostalgic GTA gamer it's a great
way to revisit these classic action
games take on missions or wreak some
havoc and destruction there are no rules
and there's no wrong way to play you can
buy a digital copy of GTA the trilogy on
ps4 for 3499 want to be a Master
Assassin check out Assassin's Creed the
etsy okay
Shin venture forth through the
critically acclaimed single-player
campaigns of assassins creed two
Brotherhood and revelations as Ezio
learn the ways of the assassins and get
your vengeance for your family through
Renaissance Italy then Rome then finally
16th century Constantinople get this
collection for Xbox one and ps4 for 5999
if you're shopping for a zombie fan
check out the Dead Rising triple pack
the Dead Rising series is perfect for
lovers of survival horror beat-'em-up
games smash hordes of zombies using
anything and everything as a weapon this
digital bundle includes Dead Rising dead
rising 2 and dead rising off the record
available for ps4 and Xbox one for 59-49
for those nostalgic call of duty fans we
recommend some of the classics call of
duty 2 3 and black ops call of duty
infinite warfare came out this year but
sometimes it's nice to get back to your
first person shooter roots take your
call of duty fan back through the past
decade with digital downloads of series
standards call of duty 2 3 and black ops
2 and 3 are all set in World War two and
black ops is set during the Cold War
download all for the Xbox one what's
life like after the apocalypse find out
in the fallout series with three of our
favorites fallout 3 fallout new vegas
and fallout 4 the Fallout series is a
favorite among action role-playing fans
as a vault dweller you fight for
survival against the terrors of the
outside world encounter dynamic
characters and mutated creatures in
these iconic games the highest rated
among them is fallout 3 which you can
download for your xbox one for 1499
fallout new vegas open-world takes you
to the vegas strip and is also
downloadable on xbox one for 1499
fallout 4 is the most recent entry which
you can get for 59 99 on Xbox one the
sci-fi 11 gamer in your life needs the
mass effect trilogy the Mass Effect
series features three incredible role
playing third person shooters become the
galaxy's most elite soldier lead a war
and travel to unexplored star systems
Mass Effect mass effect 2 and mass
effect 3 are available as a trilogy
bundle on PC and
Spock's 360 and last but not least we
have halo the master chief collection we
might be cheating here because this
collection comes with four games instead
of three but hey more bang for your buck
fans of the first person shooter halo
series get halo combat evolved
anniversary halo 2 halo 3 and Halo 4 in
this set this is one of the best
compilations out there get the Master
Chief's complete story for xbox one for
only 29 99 and those are your top gaming
trilogy's once you buy your trilogy of
choice what better way to enjoy a triple
pack of games than with pizza hut's
triple treat box the triple treat box is
a limited-time holiday offer which
includes two medium one topping pizzas
breadsticks and the ultimate Hershey's
chocolate chip cookie all packed into
three medium pizza boxes and wrapped in
an exciting holiday themed box every
specially marked triple treat box
includes ten dollars off an Xbox game
and a chance to win an Xbox one s and a
custom red Pizza Hut controller Pizza
Hut is giving them away every hour until
December 24th you can find a code on the
inside front flap of especially mark
triple treat box and enter it at Pizza
Hut xbox one esscom for a chance to
instantly win an Xbox one s happy gaming
and happy eating I'm chastity and I'll
see you next time
you